-It is time for "Tonight Show
Hashtags." Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Now, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag,
and we ask you
guys to respond to that topic.
So, since this week is
the "WandaVision" finale,
I sent out the hashtag
"RealLifePlotTwist."
And I asked you guys
to tell us about a time
when something totally
unexpected happened to you.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you so much
for playing along.
We love doing this
with you guys,
so thank you for doing that.
Tonight, I thought I'd
share some of my favorite
"RealLifePlotTwist"
responses from you guys.
This first one
is from @GoingGonza.
He says...
This one's from @mgblazin --
or blzin27.
He says...
A lot of plot twists
in that one.
This one is from @LukeThatHunts.
He says...
Oh!
-Ohhhh!
[ Cymbal crash ]
-Oh! [ Laughs ]
You have to laugh, man.
-That's a plot twist.
-You have to laugh.
-Yeah.
-This one's from @Kyle27LIT.
He says...
She got you, man.
-Got him.
-She got you, man.
-That's The Roots' tour bus.
-Oh, yeah.
-This one's from @Trishamott.
She says...
-Aww!
-I love that.
That's a movie right there, man.
-Yeah.
-"Hit On Me."
[ Laughter ]
-Really? That's the --
-Yeah, just go around
and just hit-and-run.
"Hmm? Anything?"
-"Susan Sarandon.
'Hit On Me.'"
-Yeah, "Coming this Christmas."
-[ Imitates
tires screeching, crash ]
-The roads are dangerous...
and also romantic.
This one's from @DudeFromBurg.
He said...
-Aah!
-Oof!
-Wow!
-Ow.
-I misread.
[ Breathes deeply ]
Sorry.
I must have misread
the situation...
the situation,
because I thought that...
This one's from @tayraeswift.
She says...
-Wow.
-Small world.
-That's the other Taylor Swift.
-I mean, but, again,
how close are you?
You don't know that
your second cousin's a singer
trying to make it
in the business?
-I mean, maybe, you know,
it's the daughter of
the excommunicated brother.
-Yeah.
He's cut off from the family.
-Yeah, but how long was
he cut off, Tariq?
-He's been cut off
for like 18 years now.
-Oh, so you never knew
she existed.
-No, I mean -- Well, he did.
But, you know, he also --
He felt badly because he's
been ousted from the family.
So, one day, he breaks down --
-He wanted to come back.
He wanted top come back in,
man, get a little --
-He says, "When you get home
from school today,
I want to talk to you
about something."
You know?
[ Laughter ]
-What is he smoking?
It feels like a menthol.
-Yeah.
-It's, like, a menthol,
a Marlboro menthol.
-Yeah. Yeah, that's his thing.
-"I got to talk to you," yeah.
-"Yeah, you know the singer
Taylor Swift?
The one who has
the same name as you?
Well, it's also your cousin.
I'm sorry."
-"This Christmas."
-Right?
-"This Christmas.
Not only did she hit someone,
she didn't know...
he's also her cousin."
Alright. This last one here is
from @amyschwert.
She said...
Well, there you go.
You got one more year.
You're close.
There you have it.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.